I've been trading for 14 years. I've
made over 4 and 1/2 million dollars in
third-party verified trading profits and
hold the world record for the largest
prop firm payout of 2 and 1/2 million
dollars. And a lot of people ask me why
I don't trade the lower time frames, and
the truth is it's the reason I became
profitable. Today, I'm going to show you
the five reasons why I threw the low
time frames in the trash. Reason number
one, lower time frames turned me into a
gambling addict. Early on, and I'm
talking about a couple years into this,
I was a scalper. 1-minute chart,
5-minute chart, two monitors, six charts
up. I thought that's what serious
traders did. Sit down, go to war, take
10, 12 trades a day. I thought I was
grinding. And I thought that the more I
traded, the faster I would learn, right?
In the regular world, that's what you're
rewarded by. Working harder equals more
money. But then one bad trade comes
along, and instead of just eating the
loss, I'd hold it, double down, switch
directions, and immediately jump into
more trades trying to make it back. And
after 8 hours of this, 8 hours glued to
a screen, I check my P&L, and I'm either
massively red or up like 40 bucks. And
the worst part is I couldn't stop. Every
candle felt like another shot. Price
pulls back, that's a setup. Wicks into a
level, setup. Little consolidation
breaks out, setup. Everything looked
like an opportunity because my brain was
just starving for the next trade. Not
only was this impacting my current day,
but I built bad habits by trading more
and more as the days passed. Bad day,
grind harder the next day. Here's what I
didn't understand at the time. Lower
time frames trick your brain into seeing
patterns that aren't there. I like to
call it trader hallucination. You get
three green candles on a 1-minute chart,
and your brain goes, "Trend!" But that's
just 3 minutes of data. That's nothing.
That's just noise. Your brain doesn't
care though. It's wired to find patterns
everywhere, even where they don't exist.
And it gets worse. Your brain takes
whatever little bit of information is on
the screen, builds a whole story around
it, and treats that story like it's the
full picture. So, you see a wick into a
level on the 1-minute, and your brain
immediately writes the movie. Smart
money just grabbed liquidity. This is
reversing. I got to get it. But, you're
completely ignoring the higher time
frames. You're ignoring the global
macroeconomic environment and the actual
market conditions. You're ignoring
everything that actually matters, and
your brain never flags what's missing.
It just works with what it sees and
feels confident about. Or, you trick
yourself into feeling confident about
it. That's confirmation bias. That's why
I kept taking terrible trades and
feeling smart doing it. I wasn't stupid.
My brain was just doing what it's built
to do. Find patterns and tell stories.
It's great for survival, but it's
horrible for trading. It took me years
to realize that while sometimes the
lower time frame will give you more
opportunities, they also give you more
chances to be wrong. And that fast
feedback loop, win, lose, win, lose,
that's not trading. That's a slot
machine. Pull the lever, get a result,
machine resets, pull it again. I was
addicted to the action and not the
outcome. And I kept asking myself, "Why
can't I stop?" I could see the account
statement, and the math clearly wasn't
working. But, I couldn't walk away from
the screen. It took me a long time to
find out there's an actual scientific
reason for why this happens, and it's
got nothing to do with discipline. Which
leads to reason number two, your brain
literally cannot handle it. Now, here's
something that most traders never think
about. Your brain has a limited tank of
decision-making fuel. Every decision you
make throughout the day, what to eat,
what to wear, how to deal with that
annoying email, it all pulls from the
same tank. And when it's empty, the
quality of your decisions just falls off
a cliff. They actually studied this with
judges, like actual judges in a
courtroom. Same judges, same types of
cases, same everything. In the morning,
they were granting parole at way higher
rates. By the afternoon, though, almost
nobody got approved. Not because the
cases got worse, because the judges'
brains were fried. They'd made so many
decisions that by the afternoon, their
brain just defaulted to the easiest
answer, which was no. Now, think about
what that means on a 1-minute chart.
Every candle that closes is a decision.
Do I get in? Do I get out? Move my stop?
Add to this? Hold? That's It's five
micro decisions per candle. On a
one-minute chart, that's hundreds of
decisions per hour. Do that for a
four-hour session and your brain has
processed over a thousand decisions.
You're done. You're absolutely cooked.
And you don't even feel it happening
because the decline is so gradual. Your
first trade of the day, beautiful. Clean
entry, follow the plan, proper risk.
Trade number eight, however, you're
chasing entries, moving stops, sizing up
to make it back, and you think it's a
discipline issue. It's not. Your brain
just ran out of gas. Here's the part
that changed everything for me. I
learned that your brain basically runs
on two systems. Think of it like two
workers in your head. One is fast,
automatic, emotional, runs on instinct.
It's the thing that catches the ball
thrown at your face. It reacts without
thinking, and it never gets tired. The
other one is slow, deliberate,
analytical, careful. It's the one that
actually solves problems and weighs
consequences. But that slow one, it
needs energy and it fatigues. So, what
happens on a lower time frame? You start
the session using that slow, careful
system. You're checking structure,
reading the bias, calculating risk. But
as the decisions pile up, that system
taps out, and the fast, reactive one
takes over. You stop analyzing and start
reacting. You stop following your plan,
and you start following your gut. And in
trading, your gut is almost always
wrong. Liquidity sweeps, stop hunts,
fake breakouts, they exist because the
crowd's gut reaction is predictable. The
market literally punishes reactive
decisions. And lower time frames put you
in a state where reactive decisions are
all you've got left. There's one more
thing, and this is a sneaky one. When
your brain hits a hard question, it
quietly swaps it for an easier one. You
don't even notice it happening. A hard
question is, does this setup align with
my daily process, the higher time frame
structure, my risk parameters? The
question your brain actually answers is,
is price going my way right now?
Completely different questions. But when
you're on a one-minute chart and price
is pumping and you're green on the
trade, your brain can't tell the
difference. So, once I understood this,
that is not about trying harder, it's
not about being more disciplined, it's
literally how your brain is wired. The
question became what happens when you
actually give your brain space to do its
job. And that answer changed everything
about how I see the markets. But, real
quick before I get into this, if you're
watching this and you want to start
putting this stuff into practice on a
trading account without risking your own
money, I trade with Apex Trader Funding.
It's the firm I use to hit a two and a
half million dollar payout. They let you
trade a funded account, keep the
profits, and right now if you want a
discount on any of their eval accounts,
I'll drop my link below. It's the best
deal you're going to find. All right,
let me show you what happened when I
finally slowed down. Reason number
three, you're standing too close to see
the actual picture. Here's something
that took me way too long to figure out.
Whatever strategy you use, whatever
setups, whatever signals, whatever
system you've built, you can probably
find those patterns on a one-minute
chart. They're technically there. But
just because you can see something
doesn't mean that it means anything. A
level on a one-minute chart might just
be a reaction to a news headline that
gets blown through 30 seconds later.
That same level on the daily, that's
where real money stepped in. Real
participation, real conviction from the
people who actually move markets. Same
concept on paper, completely different
weight behind it. Think about it this
way. If I showed you a single sentence
from a book with no context, you could
interpret it a hundred different ways.
But if I showed you the full chapter,
the meaning is obvious. It's just the
fact that you're so zoomed in that you
can't see what's going on around you.
And here's why this hits so hard from a
brain standpoint. When you're watching
price on a one-minute chart in real
time, your brain is building a story
candle by candle. You're watching it
unfold and unconsciously writing a
narrative as goes. This is trending,
buyers are stepping in, this is about to
break out. The problem is you're writing
that story live, filling in the plot as
each candle prints. And humans are
terrible at that. We create cause and
effect stories from random events
because it makes us feel like we
understand what's happening even when we
don't. On a daily chart, you're not
writing the story. You're reading the
finished chapter. The candle already
closed, the move already happened, the
level already held or didn't. You're not
watching a building go up brick by brick
trying to guess what it's going to be.
Now, there's also this thing where
extreme moves tend to snap back towards
the average. On a 1-minute chart, you
see a massive spike and your brain goes,
"Breakout. I got to get in." So, you
chase it and price pulls right back
because extreme moves regress. You just
bought the top. On a daily chart, that
same spike is just a wick, one data
point, not a trend change. A higher time
frame lets you see the completed picture
instead of catching you in the middle of
something you don't fully understand
yet. And here's where I want to mention
something. There's a book called
Thinking Fast and Slow by Daniel
Kahneman, a psychologist who won the
Nobel Prize in economics. And everything
I've been talking about in this video,
it's all in there. The two systems in
your brain, the decision fatigue, seeing
patterns in tiny samples, making up
narratives from noise, the
overconfidence. He spent decades
studying how people make decisions under
uncertainty, which is literally what
trading is. Now, when I read that book,
I didn't learn anything new about the
markets. I learned why I'd been failing
in them. Every trap I fell into on lower
time frames documented. And the answer
was always the same, slow down, cut the
noise, let your analytical brain
actually work. That's what higher time
frames do, not as a preference and not
as a style, as a biological necessity. I
remember the first time that this really
clicked. This was around 2020. I'd found
prop firms and was trying to get
consistent enough to actually see a
payout. Now, one night I did my analysis
on the daily chart, identified key
level, saw that price was pulling into
an area where I expected buyers to step
in. I marked my entry, set my stop, and
I went to sleep. Now, when I woke up the
next morning, I was in the trade, but by
noon, it was at my target. That one
trade made me more than two weeks of
scalping combined, and I spent maybe 15
minutes on it. Now, here's what really
got me. If I'd been staring at the same
price action on a 5-minute chart in real
time, watching it tick down at that
level, I would have panicked. I would
have thought it was breaking down, and I
probably would have shorted it. Same
market, same day, same exact level.
Different time frame, however, opposite
result. And honestly, that's when I knew
that I was never going back. But here's
what I wasn't ready for. This switch
didn't just make me a better trader, it
changed my entire life. And I'm not
being dramatic. So, reason number four
why I ditched the lower time frames is
it gave me my life back. There's a
concept that Kahneman talks about called
the focusing illusion. Basically,
nothing in life is as important as you
think it is while you're thinking about
it. When you're on a 1-minute chart, the
trade you're in feels like the most
important thing on the planet. Your mood
swings with every single tick. You can't
be present, you can't hold a
conversation, and you're checking your
phone every 30 seconds. And I remember
sitting at dinner once, checking my
phone over and over, not texting anyone,
just watching a 1-minute candle close on
the ES. But that's what lower time
frames turned me into, physically there
but mentally gone. I just was not
present. Higher time frames break that
completely. You do your analysis, set
your levels, and walk away. The trade
runs in the background of your life
instead of eating up the whole
foreground. And that's the whole point.
for freedom, right? None of you got into
this game to work another full-time job
sitting at your desk for 8 to 12 hours.
While you can, and many do, for most
people it's negative expectancy. You
have to have a real passion for trading
if that's what your goal is. But there's
another piece to this. When you scalp,
your brain judges the entire day based
on the worst moment. You might have
eight winners and two losers. Great day
on paper, but if the last trade was a
gut punch, your brain records the whole
session as bad. That roller coaster
compounds over weeks and months. It
grinds you down in ways you don't even
notice until you're completely fried.
So, higher time frame trading smooths
all of that out. You analyze, you enter,
you check back later. The emotional
intensity never spikes the way it does
tick by tick. But there's also this trap
where scalpers keep chasing bigger
highs. A $200 win that felt amazing in
month one feels like nothing by month
six. So, you size up, you overtrade, you
force setups that aren't there, not
because the strategy says to, but
because your brain needs a bigger
dopamine hit. So, thinking about the
bigger picture from the higher time
frame, the reward isn't the rush of a
quick win. It's the calm of a plan that
played out exactly how you drew it up.
But, here's something that nobody really
talks about in the trading space. When
you stop burning your brain out on 50
decisions a day, something shifts in how
you handle risk. And that shift is what
actually built the track record people
see. Which leads to reason number five,
the higher time frames forced me to
master risk. This is the one thing that
ties everything else together. When
you're taking 15 trades a day, each one
feels small. The risk feels manageable
because it's just one trade. But, the
cumulative damage, commission, slippage,
emotional errors stacking on top of each
other, that is brutal. So, your account
is bleeding from a thousand little cuts
and telling yourself it's fine because
no single one is that deep. Now,
comparatively, when you move to the
higher time frames and you're taking
three to five trades a week, every trade
carries real weight. You can't spray and
pray. You have to be surgical. Your
entry, your stop, your size, your
target. Everything has to be done right
don't get 15 tries, you get three, maybe
five. And that constraint is the best
thing that's ever happened to me. It
allows you to actually slow down and
review what's going on. When you're
taking five trades a day, you're adding
extra work in the evening by having to
analyze five different scenarios.
Sometimes you don't even remember what
you were doing. Now, those higher time
frames with the lower frequency, you
actually learn so much more. You take a
planned trade with defined risk. If it
stops you out, you process it cleanly
because you're not getting hammered with
losses every 10 minutes. You get actual
space between your trades and your brain
actually gets to reset. So, let's talk
about the sunk cost fallacy in trading.
It feels like the more and more time
that you put in, that you actually need
a result. And the lower time frames feed
that because of how much time you're
spending in front of the markets. You
sat there for hours, you stared at the
charts, and you did the work, but now
you need a trade and results to show for
it. But, because my whole approach was
built around those higher time frames,
which were slower, more deliberate,
predetermined risk, and predetermined
plan, I could execute and actually reset
properly every single day. I was not in
a state to make 15 good decisions a day.
I could barely make it through a normal
day. You know, how many of you logically
can make 15 good decisions in one day? I
make the argument that most people can't
even make one. So, you don't need to
make things harder for yourself. Just
slow down and try to make proper
decisions. And that's what led to my
consistency. That's what led to a record
payout. I just needed patience in
following my plan. Now, that payout
didn't come from 10,000 trades. It came
from a stretch of high conviction setups
where I managed my risk, I had a higher
timeframe bias, and I followed the plan.
So, fewer decisions, but more clarity.
Right? You've probably seen all the
traders out there posting P&Ls, and you
think that they were just glued to the
screen all day pressing buttons. But,
for the majority of traders out there,
it's the complete opposite. The less I
did, the more I made. And that's not
just a flex, that's just to show you how
it works when you stop fighting your own
brain. So, when someone asked me why I
threw the lower timeframes in the trash,
that's exactly why. 15 years, over 4 and
1/2 million dollars in verified profits,
and a lot of lessons that didn't need to
take as long as they did. Those lower
timeframes didn't just cost me money,
they cost me time, they cost me peace,
and they almost cost me my trading
career. So, everything I just showed
you, the brain science, the timeframe
shift, the risk management, that's the
foundation. But, knowing why lower
timeframes don't work is only half of
it. You still need to know what to
actually do when you open the daily
chart. And that's what I teach in the
Trading Apprentice. My full process, how
I break down the market, find my levels,
structure my week around two or three
high conviction trades instead of 50
random ones. You get me directly, live
sessions, real-time breakdowns, and a
community of traders who've already made
the switch. If this video clicked for
you, that's where you need to go next.
Link is in the description. As always,
thanks for watching, and I'll see you
guys in the next one.